foreign
[Music]
hi there I'm Holt also a developer
Advocate from Google Cloud team based in
Austin Texas
one of the most challenging problems to
solve for an organization is
discoverability of information
many times data will be scattered across
a bunch of different sources some might
be in docs some in databases others in
web pages
this makes it difficult for employees
and customers to find just what they're
looking for whether it be internal data
or on a public site
there are three main challenges when
building a search service for an
Enterprise
one is the service level requirements
for any Enterprise search service is
high most companies don't have time or
budget to build a service that is
capable of handling large amounts of
data in a wide variety of formats all
while being scalable and available 24 7.
the Second Challenge is that traditional
keyword search is too restricted
especially for users who are familiar
with AI powered search and
recommendations every day on YouTube
Instagram and other apps
these experiences are a standard today
but it's much more difficult to
implement
the third challenge is how to take
advantage of generative Ai and LMS that
are the Pinnacle of information
retrieval technology
generative AI app builder with
Enterprise search from Google Cloud
provides a simple to set up service that
unifies all this information together
and makes it straightforward defined
gen app builder supports creating search
engines and chat interfaces in this
session we'll be focusing on how to
bring the power of search to your
applications
it's an out of the box solution which
means you can deploy the fully managed
search engine quickly you don't have to
build and Lead an entire devops team to
manage it
it also utilizes semantic search which
provides the next-gen search experience
as we'll discuss later
Enterprise search provides llm based
summarization multimodal search and
chappa integration utilizing the latest
in generative AI technology
one of the greatest features of gen app
builder is its ease of use for
developers let's get started by looking
at the onboarding experience
in mind that this product is in Early
Access and the process might look
slightly different once it's publicly
available
let's go through the process of setting
up a basic search engine for a public
website structured data and unstructured
data
first you go to the generative AI app
builder section in the Google Cloud
console
then you enable the API
then you select create a search engine
then you give it a name and choose the
data type let's go through the website
process first
after our search engine has been created
we just need to add the sites we want to
include
if we open the advanced view that we can
exclude certain sites as well
for this example let's search over the
Google Cloud website cloud.google.com
after setting the website we now have a
view of the URLs included in our search
engine you can also add more websites if
you want
and just that fast the search engine has
already indexed our website we can now
click on preview search to try it out
the preview page lets you try out your
search engine in a browser you can
select a desktop or mobile view
a search for another Google Cloud
product document AI shows lots of
relevant results for the product
we can also look for more detailed
information like how to handle nested
entities with document AI
now let's go back and create a new
search engine this time for structured
data you can import the data from cloud
storage in a structured format like Json
or from a bigquery table
let's import data from bigquery we'll
use a public data set of movies that can
be found on kaggle
importing this data requires very little
setup because the tool will figure out
the schema for you all you have to do is
provide a link to the data and it'll get
ingested
once it finishes importing we can test
the search engine out just like the
previous one
the process for unstructured data works
pretty similar to structured data
unstructured data doesn't follow a
schema usually this will be in the form
of documents like PDFs
you create a search engine for
unstructured data then you can import
files from cloud storage
in this case I'm importing alphabet
earnings reports
once they're imported you can search the
files to find specific information
now we've explored the main types of
search engines let's see how we can use
them in our applications
if we go to the integration page the
console provides simple ways to
integrate this new search engine into an
application
you can go to the API tab to get
pre-written API calls and code samples
to integrate this into server
applications or to build your own UI
or you can copy paste the HTML code in
the widget tab to embed this directly
into your website
going to the configure menu from this
page takes you to the widget settings
where you can configure autocomplete
among other features for the search
engine widget
for structured data we can also control
more specific settings such as the
fields that are shown the widget like
the movie title description ratings and
add thumbnail images
the analytics page provides aggregate
metrics for the search engine including
session information click-through rate
top queries and devices
now I'm going to toss it over to Kaz to
talk about semantic search
[Music]
so we have learned how Enterprise search
makes a developers work much easier to
build an AI product search engine in a
short time
in my part I'd like to dive deeper into
this semantic search technology provided
by Enterprise search and how it would
change the search experience in a wide
variety of businesses
many of you might ask what is semantic
search by the way
to understand what it is we need to know
the major shift undergoing in the IT
industry
the traditional ID systems most data is
organized as a structured or tabular
data using simple keywords labels and
categories in databases and search
engines
that means the foundation of the user
experience you'd have with the usual it
system for information between four and
recommendation
in contrast AI powered search services
arrange data into a simple data
structure known as embedding
what is happening
let's see how AI organizes data using
embeddings
once trained with a specific content
like text images tweets or anything
AI creates a space called embedding
space which is essentially a map of the
content's Mini
AI can identify the location of each
content on the map that is what
embedding is
let's take an example where our text
discusses movies music artists with a
distribution of 10 2 and 30 percent
respectively
in this case the AI can create an
embedding with the three values 0.1
.02 and 0.3 in three-dimensional space
but it's not not that this is a
simplified example for explanation
in reality everything space may have
hundreds or 1000 or 2 000 of damages
that can represent millions of different
categories of the content
and the AI can put content with similar
meanings CrossFit together
in the same space
according to the Google's machine
learning crash course
embedding refers to the process of
mapping High dimensional raw data such
as images or text which have tens or
thousands of millions of Dimensions to a
lower dimensional space with hundreds or
thousands of Damages using deep learning
models
this is done to extract the meaning or
semantics of the data and create a map
of the contents meaning
and this is how Google organizes data
across various services like Google
search YouTube play and many others to
provide certain result and
recommendations with relevant content
embeddings can also be used to represent
the different types of things in
businesses such as products users user
activities
conversations
music and videos
signals from iot sensors and so on
let's see what real ambient space looks
like
this is an embedding space for
handwritten digit images
the embedding serve grouped based on how
similar their shapes are
this is another embedding space for text
sentences
even though they are written in
different languages the sentences with
similar meanings are grouped together
embeddings is an essential technology
uterized by Google search to enhance its
semantic search abilities along with
keyword search
when a search query is entered a
language model based on birth converts
it into an embedding
web pages are also transformed into
embeddings beforehand enabling this
service to conduct a vector search to
locate your web pages that matches the
equality's intention in the emitting
space
in the past Google research used on the
a keyword search model
this model sometimes gave you too many
math textbooks for students when someone
searched for Mass practice books for
adults
but now with thematic search it can
understand the intention behind the
query
and show the most helpful result at the
top
this is the major shift in the IT
industry especially 4gi information
retrieval and recommendations
AI is now bringing a crucial role in the
human computer interaction in those
applications
it organizes data into ambinix which
represent the user's intention the
meaning of a product
or many other things you have in your
business
this creates a new level of search
experience studies becoming the new
standard
now let's examine the semantic search
experience provided to this Enterprise
search
in this demo we use 20 PDF files of
Google research papers that have a total
of 400 pages
what if you are asked by your manager
can you investigate what is video
localized narratives and annotated
diversity by scrutinizing into 400 pages
the solution is import all files into
Enterprise search and run a query
let's see how it works
after importing your files just enter a
text query what our video localized
narratives
then Enterprise search quickly finds the
relevant pages from all the files by
understanding the text query and its
intent and also the meaning of the all
400 pages
it's not just a keyword search but
search by meaning with the AI powered
symmetric search technology we built
with Google search and rungage models
also you notice that Enterprise search
generates a summary of the query result
this summarization is automatically done
by a large language model in the search
engine
instead of looking at each page one by
one you can instantly get the gist of
this search result
and you can trust it because the summary
is generated from the real business
reports not just generated text from
Nowhere by an chatbot
this is the way you can use the power of
the generative AI with the
responsibility for business use cases
here's another demo
this is a sneak preview that shows you
this the possible use case of Enterprise
search soon
later this year Enterprise search will
enable developers to import their own
embedics as a search attribute
that means not only the document or web
text you can also execute symmetric
search on any arbitrary medium or entity
be presented with the embeddings
for example if you import multi-model
and meanings that capture the meaning of
the product images then you can run a
text query for finding the products by
what the images mean not only from the
product description
this demo data set is provided by
melgary a Marketplace app with over 50
million downloads in the United States
it will be possible to enable such a
rich user experience with the
multi-modal semantic search not only for
our wheelchair businesses like Mercury
but also for Financial Health Care or
other various Industries
[Music]
let's recap what we covered this session
as Holt introduced Enterprise search
gives you an out of the box developer
experience whether it's a web pages or
table editor or documents like PDF files
you can just bring them in
Enterprise search automatically builds
this schemer and the search index for
your data with a simple UI flow
second point is the schematic search
it searches by content's meaning not
just by keywords
behind the scene the documents are
converted into embeddings enabling the
next-gen search experience
the last point is the llm capability
with the summarization Enterprise search
saves your time for opening and looking
at every Pages for understanding what
you get with the search results
instead you can get the gist of them in
seconds
dramatically improving the information
retrieval productivity in a wide variety
of businesses
also the multimodal feature will allow
you to search from images text and many
different mediums entities
in your businesses
these llm features aren't based not on
the virtual out of nowhere outputs from
AI chatbots but grounded with business
facts with responsibility
to get started with Gen app builder and
Enterprise search please check out the
Gen AI page on cloud.google.com
that was our system thank you so much
thank you so much for watching and enjoy
the rest of i o
[Music]